(light ambient music)
- It's a great life.
I wouldn't change it for anything.
I was a model.
I was always in heels and
pumps and platform shoes,
and I worried about my
weight. There just came a time
I just said, “Enough,
I'm not happy anymore.”
I came to Alaska with one dog
and about $500 in my pocket
'cause I wanted to be a sled-dog musher.
(light piano music)
I knew that life
in Alaska was for me basically the moment
I stepped off the airplane.
I got here and the
mountains just blew me away.
It's like how some people
feel when they see the ocean.
I personally don't feel
isolated at all in Alaska
because I'm surrounded by a lot
of dogs and a lot of family.
Racing is fun, and I enjoy that.
But there is a great need
for rescue in Alaska.
We take dogs that are rejected
from other teams and other kennels.
They all have their own unique stories,
and this is, to me, the most
rewarding work we can do.
I'm training for the Iditarod 2016.
The Iditarod is the world's longest
and probably most well
known sled dog race.
It's a thousand miles, starts in Anchorage
and goes to Nome, and it
covers some amazing country
and it goes up on the coast
off of the Bering Sea.
To be on the sled with
the dogs feels amazing.
You're part of this wild
world where there's caribou
and there's moose, and
you got the sunrise,
you got the sunset, you
got the stars over you,
you got the moon over you.
And it's a great feeling
to be a part of that.